so what we're going to do in this video
is think about equivalent fractions so
let's say we have the fraction
three
fourths
and i want to think about what is an
equivalent number of eighths so
three-fourths is equal to
how many eighths
and to represent that how many i could
put a question mark there but instead of
a question mark i'll just put a letter
so what should y be three-fourths is
equal to
y-eighths what does y need to be to make
this true and before i tell you to go
pause this video and try to work on it
on your own which i will do in a little
bit i'll give you a little bit of a hint
so let's try to represent three-fourths
or i'll represent it for you
so i will do it with this rectangle so
i'm going to divide it into four equal
sections
so let's see that would be dividing it
roughly in half i'm hand drawing it so
it's not perfect but these should be
equal sections the areas of each of
these sections should be
equal
so there you go this is my hand drawn
version of that and so three of those
four
and i will do that in purple
three of those four it could be
one two
and then
just for kicks i will do this one out
here so that is three-fourths right over
there so if i were to think about this
in terms of eights so i'm going to draw
another hole
but this time instead of just splitting
them into fourths i'm going to split it
into eighths
so let's do the fourths first just
because it's easy to look at the one
above that
so that's my fourths and then i'll
divide each of the fourths
into two so that gives me
eighths
all right almost there the drawing is
really the hardest part here
and so each of these is an eighth it's
hand drawn but imagine if there were
eight equal sections so how many eighths
is equal to three fourths pause the
video and try to work it out on your own
all right well we can just look at this
visually so
this first fourth we could say that's
equivalent to filling out this eighth
and this eighth
so that first fourth is equal to
two-eighths
this second fourth is equal to another
two
of these eighths and then this third
fourth is equal to another two
of the eighths
so how many eighths have i shaded in
well i have one two three four
five six 8. so i have 6
over 8 so 3
4 is equivalent to 6 8. so in this
scenario
y is equal to 6 8. or we could say 6 8
is equal to y
now let's do
another example
so we could see here in this top circle
is we've divided it into six equal
sections so each of these are one of the
six equal sections or one sixth and we
can see that one two three four of them
are shaded in so we have represented in
that top circle that is four
four
out of 6.
so what i want to think about is how
many thirds are equivalent to 4 6. pause
this video and think about it so once
again how many thirds are equivalent to
4 6. instead of just putting a question
mark there i'll put the letter x so what
should x be for these two things to be
equivalent or another way to think about
it is 4
over 6
is equal to
x
over
over 3. 4 6 is equal to how many thirds
all right now let's do this together
and so one way you could think about it
let's see for one third
first to be make this equal to one third
it looks like that
is equivalent to
what i am
circling in the orange up here and that
also makes sense if i were to divide a
third into two
so now i would have this would be a
sixth and that would be a sixth so you
need two sixths to make up a third or
each third is equivalent to two-sixths
so
this is one-third right over here
and that is equivalent to two of these
sixths
but we are not completely done yet we
have another two sixths so we could say
those two six are equivalent to another
third and it's a little tricky because
they didn't put this sixth next to that
sixth but you could imagine if we were
to move let's say we were to move this
sixth so i'm gonna color this one in
white
so if i were to move that sixth to right
over here
so we're shading this one in instead
so then you can see
that these two sixths right over here
these two sixths
are equivalent to
this third
right over there
so what you can see is is that our 4 6
and remember i moved this one over so
i'm not shading this one in anymore
but you can see the 4 6 that i've shaded
in is equivalent to two-thirds or
another way to say it is x would be
equal to two
x would be equal to two four-sixths is
equal to x thirds or four-sixths is
equal to two-thirds